What’s the largest animal you can think
of?
Okay, that’s probably too vague of a question,
your mind probably went straight to the oceans,
picturing deep sea leviathans like the mighty
Blue Whale.
Let’s go a little bit closer, shall we?
What about on land, what’re the biggest
animals that live up here with us, above the
water?
Elephants, maybe?
What about rhinos?
Then again, hippos are up there too, in the
same kind of ballpark, all pretty huge.
What about cows, they can grow to be pretty
big, right?
Especially with all the crazy growth hormones
that meat manufacturers pump into them these
days.
Well, what if there was something out there
bigger than all of those?
Imagine it, some huge beast roaming the wilderness
that easily towered above any creature you’ve
ever seen in your life.
This thing would be massive, striding across
the world, towering above the meager height
of a human being.
Now, imagine that this… thing, whatever
it was, wasn’t just big, but kept getting
bigger.
Sure, all of this might sound like the premise
for the next Godzilla or Cloverfield movie,
but while Big Charlie might not be king of
the monsters, it certainly lives up to that
first part of its nickname.
Of course, the SCP Foundation calls it SCP-4158;
“Big Charlie” is just the playful nickname
that the owners gave it, although none of
them are sure who was the first to call the
creature by that name.
Standing on four long legs at 3.4 meters tall
when the Foundation first discovered it, SCP-4158
was about one-and-three-fifths times as tall
as famous professional basketball player Shaquille
O’Neal.
But since then, well, like we said, Big Charlie
is getting bigger day by day.
The creature appears to be tangentially related
to the bovine family of mammals, essentially
making it a ginormous cow.
However, SCP-4158 lacks the facial structure
and features that you might expect to see
on the faces at your local farm.
The creature has thin, translucent skin, which
is so fragile that it often tears easily,
and anyone observing SCP-4158 can often see
the bones and internal organs within.
Gross.
It possesses a large, bulbous head with a
protrusion at the front, almost like a beak.
As well as that, its huge eyes are foggy,
a milky white color which seems to suggest
that SCP-4158 is, at least partially, blind.
The large, cattle-like mammal is incredibly
skinny, almost to the point where its bones
stick out from underneath its skin.
Its legs are longer than the rest of its colossal
body and seem barely able to support the animal’s
weight.
On description alone, you can’t help but
feel sorry for the poor creature and its sorry
state of living.
Normally, Big Charlie is mostly calm and docile,
barely acknowledging the Foundation personnel
that come to examine it, feed it, or clean
its containment cell.
Held in a heavy containment zone, SCP-4158
is fed through a five-meter trough on the
far east wall of its cell, surviving on a
diet of raw beef, hay, wood, and bricks.
Not the typical “grass-only” eating habits
you’d expect from normal cows.
But according to the Foundation’s extensive
testing on the creature, its diet doesn’t
seem to be what is causing SCP-4158 to keep
growing at the rate it has been.
The mass of Big Charlie is in some sort of
state of perpetual increase, meaning its size
and weight are always growing.
And it is because of this continuous growth
that every week the Foundation is forced to
shear off great swathes of excess meat from
the creature, cleaving off its flesh and incinerating
the mass, all while Big Charlie is still alive.
Before you start dialing PETA’s hotline,
it’s also worth mentioning Big Charlie can’t
feel pain.
What’s more, testing has revealed that the
meat taken from SCP-4158 is USDA Utility Grade
beef, the kind that would normally come from
older cattle.
Utility Grade meat has no fat marbling, so
it isn’t as tender or as flavorsome as other
more premium grades, but would normally be
used in canned and processed food products.
And, despite the Foundation destroying the
excess that they cut off of Big Charlie as
a precaution, in theory, the meat is still
good to eat and possesses no anomalous properties.
Then again, would you really want to eat a
burger made from SCP-4158?
If left unchecked and allowed to grow for
longer than a week, SCP-4158 will begin to
form new features, limbs, organs and sometimes
even genitals will sprout from random places
all over its body.
The previous record for Big Charlie’s most
substantial growth was when he increased to
eight and a half meters tall, that’s over
three-fifths the height of the Hollywood sign,
and over one-and-a-half times the average
height of a giraffe.
At this immense size, Charlie had developed
seven legs, four stomachs, three tongues,
and numerous other extremities before the
SCP Foundation cut him back down to size.
And we mean they literally cut him back down.
So, what exactly is this thing?
It’s like a giant cow but not actually a
cow, even though its flesh is identical to
beef.
And it’s not a destructive rampaging monster
either, showing no hostility towards humans
even when they are shearing its excess body
mass away.
Could it be some kind of failed genetic experiment?
An attempt to solve hunger by engineering
a creature that can not only stay alive but
keep growing after having its meat cut away?
If that were true, it would make SCP-4158
a literal cash cow for the meat industry.
Well, we’ve got kind of a funny story about
that, actually…
Big Charlie was first encountered by the Foundation
back in December 2004, in Crewdson, Indiana.
A number of calls had been made to the area’s
local animal control services, with reports
of a large cow with mange roaming the nearby
Highway 17.
Two officers belonging to the animal control
department were sent out to investigate these
reports, and what they found was SCP-4158,
wandering aimlessly, but unlike any cow, they
had ever seen.
The officers called local police, where a
Foundation plant caught wind of what they
had found and called in containment specialists.
The case was closed after the animal control
officers were given amnestics, and a cover
story was put in place about a cow with mange
that was put down where it had been found.
In reality, the SCP Foundation rounded up
old Big Charlie and transported it to safety
with little resistance from the animal.
They were able to trace the creature’s origin
back to somewhere called Butcher’s Block,
a nearby slaughterhouse.
The manager of the establishment, one Jeff
Fine, and a single employee named Barney Mossman,
were brought in by the Foundation for questioning.
Another employee, Rory Gildson, was also retrieved
from his home, after having called in sick
to work that day.
Barney Mossman, the first of the Butcher’s
Block employees to be interviewed, stated
that SCP-4158 had been called “Big Charlie”
since long before he had started his job at
the slaughterhouse.
According to his testimony, he knew nothing
about where the creature had actually come
from, only that it was fed hay but would also
occasionally eat anything else it could, including
other cows.
Since joining Butcher’s Block four years
earlier, Mossman had been told not to ask
questions or to tell anyone else about SCP-4158.
The morning after the huge creature had seemingly
escaped, Mr. Fine had apparently angrily accused
both Barney and Rory of selling him out and
giving Big Charlie away to the competitors
of Butcher’s Block - even though they were
the only slaughterhouse in the area.
But Mossman was convinced that neither of
them were capable of doing something like
that, Rory apparently treated Big Charlie
like his own child, and Fine had an even stranger
relationship with the creature.
Rory Gildson, the other of Fine’s employees,
was more helpful in shedding light on SCP-4158’s
origin than Barney had been.
Rory explained that he and Jeff Fine had bought
a pregnant cow from an unknown person nine
years earlier, considering it to be a steal,
a two-for-the-price-of-one bargain.
However, one day without warning, the calf
fell out of its mother.
It wasn’t born like any ordinary cow however;
according to Gildson it had ripped through
the mother cow’s chest, and looked disgusting.
While Rory and Jeff had initially thought
the calf to be dead, they discovered it had
tried to get back into the barn after they
had hauled it outside.
Their original intention had been to sell
the creature off for scientific study or,
failing that, to a freak show.
However, after their attempts to sell the
calf failed, Jeff and Rory had decided the
best course of action would be to put the
animal down.
They had reasoned that releasing it into the
wild could have negatively affected the ecosystem,
so instead, they took a bolt pistol and pushed
it between the creature’s eyes, then fired.
But nothing happened.
Rory tried again but ended up breaking the
gun instead.
They slit the animal’s throat but it barely
bled, even butchering it there on the spot
while it was still alive did nothing.
Fine and Gildson reduced the calf to little
more than a skeleton, but it simply refused
to die.
The pair of them packaged the meat they had
removed with the rest, hoping no one would
notice or ask where it had come from.
It was a few days later that Rory realized
SCP-4158 was capable of regrowing whatever
was cut off of it.
He and his boss even tried some, and couldn’t
tell the difference.
They had their hands on a cow that would eat
anything put in front of it and that could
produce infinite meat.
The Foundation probed Rory Gildson further
for more information on the creature, learning
that SCP-4158 was sterile and incapable of
reproducing, the only one of its kind.
Rory argued that the Foundation legally couldn’t
take Big Charlie away, that the creature was
still private property.
Little did he realize, he was wrong.
But he, just like Barney Mossman, also knew
nothing about how the animal had escaped in
the first place.
Finally, Jeff Fine, the owner of the Butcher’s
Block slaughterhouse was questioned by the
Foundation.
He repeated Rory’s earlier story about the
strange calf that had been born and how it
could regenerate the flesh that was sheared
off of it.
Fine remarked that he considered it to be
a blessing.
When asked about his whereabouts on the night
SCP-4158 had escaped from Butcher’s Block,
Jeff admitted that he had been praying.
But not to God, to Big Charlie.
He had apparently been doing this every night
since realizing what the creature could do,
viewing the animal as a provider and a savior.
“I just felt something when I was around
him.
I could tell that he wanted to make this sacrifice
for us.
Ever since he tried to get into the barn after
we threw him out…
I knew he cared for us,” Fine told the Foundation,
“I would open his pen, take off my clothes
so that I was pure before him, lay down, and
receive his blessings.”
And how would he receive those blessings?
By drinking the animal’s blood.
Yeah, Jeff Fine was a real eccentric like
that.
One night, when Fine had entered the pen to
perform this weird ritual, Big Charlie had
escaped.
But his owner was convinced that there must
have been a reason for this, that the animal
had some sort of goal.
When the Foundation staff conducting Fine’s
interview dismissed this idea, the slaughterhouse
owner became enraged.
“How dare you question Big Charlie!
He knows what’s best for all of us!
I’m done here!
I don’t need to keep answering questions
like this…
Let me out!
I need to see Big Charlie!
I need to see if he’s safe!”
The Foundation believes that Jeff Fine’s
practice of worshipping SCP-4158 was not due
to any anomalous effect caused by the creature
itself.
None of the Foundation personnel tasked with
feeding, studying and shearing meat off of
Big Charlie have displayed any similar behavior
of performing abnormal religious rituals.
He really was just a huge weirdo.
As for the Butcher’s Block slaughterhouse,
Fine and the rest of his employees were given
amnestics to forget Big Charlie had ever even
existed, and the slaughterhouse was closed
under the false pretense of a health code
violation and its staff being arrested for
malpractice.
The one question that remains unanswered,
however, is the identity of the individual
that first sold Jeff Fine the cow that gave
birth to SCP-4158.
It just goes to show you though, sometimes
you don’t know where your food is coming
from.
If you lived in Indiana in late 2004, who
knows – you might have eaten some of Big
Charlie and not even realized it.
Now go check out “SCP-261 - Pan-Dimensional
Vending Machine” and “SCP-426 - I am a
Toaster” for more SCPs that might whet your
appetite!